fresh eyes are dangerous eyes one of the
reasons I've been able to be a very
successful entrepreneur and I'm
comfortable saying that is actually
grounded in lack of knowledge I'm
sitting in my office right now at Vayner
we're 13 years in we are undoubtedly one
of the largest independent advertising
agencies in the world it's just no
debate size of Revenue size of people
Global when I tell you I knew nothing
about the history or the actual current
state of the advertising industry when I
started this company that is the truth
all I knew was what we started this
conversation with which was if Pepsi and
the NHL and Campbell's and GE our early
clients did not get Twitter and Facebook
accounts they were going to leave
opportunity on the table and that's to
your point as long as all the kids that
we're trying to inspire when I say kids
I mean creative kid thinking if we can
Inspire them to solve problems that they
clearly see and not overvalue of how
everybody tried to solve it they will
create some of the most important
Innovations of all time I have a saying
I'm obsessed with which is